this last night thousands of people rang
in the new year here in las vegas
of course the pandemic forced
celebrations to scale things back
but there are still concerns about how
many people
did turn out last night sasha loftis is
on the strip tonight to explain
sasha brian many people here in las
vegas did stay home
to celebrate safely as our numbers here
in the city continue to climb
but others did choose to go out and
those we spoke with tonight say
some of the scenes they saw made them
pretty uneasy
that is what a super spreader event
looks like
if you're considering going out i urge
you to reconsider
it was an ask that many chose to ignore
this new year's eve
packing the las vegas strip even as the
covid 19 pandemic
rages on seeing some people without
their masks and just like hugging people
randomly
it's kind of scary those we spoke with
call this concerning
especially as our coronavirus numbers
continue to climb
but if we don't start making smart
choices
at the start of 2021 we will look a lot
and feel a lot more like twenty twenty
governor steve sisilak shared a serious
warning this week
as our state's positivity rate soared to
20.9 percent
friday for some it still didn't matter
none of them were taking precautions
or definitely wasn't social distancing
many locals like sonya pedowitch
celebrated at home
and were sad to see others go against
the rules two to three weeks from now is
when
they they could be experiencing covid
but she and many others hope 2021 will
bring a fresh
chance to work toward a brighter future
we could get out of this storm together
and and be
actually building the 2021 that we all
hope we can have
now it is important to note our state is
still under that statewide pause for
another few weeks through january
15th now if we don't see our numbers
improved by then there is a chance
according to the governor
that we could face tighter restrictions
here in las vegas
and across nevada for now reporting live
on the las vegas strip tonight sasha
lofus
8 news now